Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill where
the news of Muller's letter has shaken
up expectations for the Senate hearing
which was already expected to be
contentious Nancy good morning good
morning that's right you know you could
almost hear Democrats across the Capitol
ripping up their questions and starting
over last night after news of this
Muller letter broke senator Amy
Klobuchar of Minnesota told me she now
is going to want to know a lot more
about why the Attorney General didn't
seek more of Muller's input from the
outset Klobuchar is one of three
Democratic presidential candidates who
are on this committee and will grill
barbar today all of them looking to make
their mark in a crowded presidential
field another committee Democrat
Connecticut's Richard Blumenthal called
the Muller letter an unprecedented
stunning rebuke of the AG that will
devastate bars credibility within DOJ
and at this hearing now keep in mind
this is the Senate where Republicans
control the hearing the Judiciary
Committee is chaired by South Carolina's
Lindsey Graham who said on Face the
Nation just this weekend he's done with
the Muller report period end of sentence
so Graham and some of his GOP colleagues
are not expected to push bar on his
conduct in regards to the report but it
is a different situation in the house
which is controlled by Democrats bars
scheduled appearance there is now up in
the air for tomorrow because of a
dispute Margaret over the format of that
hearing Nancy thank you and you know we
could get some of the answers to these
questions if the special counsel himself
sat and answered them but there's
disagreement over whether that would be
appropriate I believe AG bar is that he
doesn't have a problem with it but we
know Lindsey Graham the senator who's
running today's hearing has said he does
not intend to call him forward for
question he said that he's done with
report but I think Nancy said it very
well when she said there now ripping up
their questions because yeah now it
seems like a very different kind of
ballgame well that's right I mean
Attorney General bar is now squarely at
the center of the stage and at least one
primary question is whether he told the
truth to the members of Congress when he
said he didn't know what Bob Miller
thought about his conclusion that's
directly on the Attorney General
leaving aside what's in the actual
report
that's something he'll have to face
today it's gonna be a very different
hearing than we would have expected
yesterday
absolutely well